hey what's going on is Bill burr in it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
and I'm checking in on you although the
way I was just coughing you should be
checking in on me what do you think it
wasn't you smoking a bunch of guys yeah
bill no I'm not I was just just I got a
little sick I got a little sick but not
tired I just got a little sick I just
wrapped on my General Hospital my 72
episode arc on General Hospital 12-hour
day six days a week and we knocked it
out and I actually got to see a sneak
peak of the obviously it's not Journal
Hospital I got to see the sneak peak of
this thing that I'm gonna be a small
part of as always I always paratroop
into things that are really cool I'm
never the main guy all right that that
that's not the road for me you know I'm
a bald redheaded male okay I know the
deal I'm in the background I get it
all right you know you don't see me cold
complaining like some of these fat
chicks out here know why he's almost at
Hawaii out here in Hollywood like oh how
come I'm not starring in a [__] movie
because you look like me with a dress
that's why okay and people invest money
and they want to make it back okay so at
some point you're gonna have to deal
with the fact that you know you're in
the van man all right you're not picking
the [__] safe the lock on the safe
anyways we wrapped on it I had a great
time I took some chances as an actor I
learned some things I learned what I
always learned whenever I go on a shoot
like that just the sheer amount of
[__] work how hard everybody works on
those things and it just kills me
whenever these politicians nobody's
politicians run for office who do they
talk about do they talk about people
busting their asses like people who
[__] write scripts and people who got
to figure out how to then you know
[__] shoot the thing and all these
different looks and now
about Joe Sixpack Joe Sixpack [__]
putting his pants on one leg at a
[__] time he's got time to go drink a
[__] six-pack you know some [__]
dope just driving around you know I
don't know what a [__] ice cream
truck he's getting more love from the
next potential President of the United
States that somebody's got to stand
there hold the [__] microphone over
some bald jackass like me for 12 hours a
day I don't know
I think these politicians are wrong
maybe if all these [__] Hollywood
people would quit [__] on half of
them maybe the hard-working people in
the movie industry would get a little
more love it's just just I'm just
thinking out loud here people anyways I
had a [__] awesome time and I got to
work with some amazing actors and you
know just great storytellers and all
that and I had a great [__] time
having said that I'm old and I'm
exhausted all right and I got to jump on
a red-eye tonight to go out fly direct
to [__] Atlantic City because I'm
doing a gig at the Borgata tomorrow
night all right I'm taking off my acting
hat and I'm putting on my standup shirt
anyway speaking of shirts did anybody
see that stupid sweater Gucci made I'm
getting all my news from Twitter by the
way I've just given into the fact that
I'm not gonna be an informed person all
right you're listening to the wrong bill
okay you want to listen to Bill Maher if
you want to if you want to listen to
someone who knows what the [__] is going
on okay you want to listen to that bill
all right you want to listen to some
[__] who reads hashtags and whatnot
you're listening to the right podcast
all right Gucci sweater one of these
[__] idiots right goes out he designs
this [__] he or she all right
it was either some dumb guy or a strong
brave woman is that mine is that I
supposed to say it politically designed
a turtleneck that was black that you for
whatever stupid [__] reason you
pulled up like right up underneath your
nose and then your mouth came through it
and then there was these big red lips
around it
so if you've seen the picture just
Google a picture of it all right
african-american people you know not all
of them I don't know how many I don't I
didn't take a [__] census start going
Jesus Christ can we stop with the
[__] blackface this is offensive you
know they said the sweater looked like
it was blackface and they immediately
made it about themselves rather than the
real issue which was that it was an
unbelievably ridiculous and ugly [__]
turtleneck sweater that's all it was it
was an ugly turn the next sweater you
know and I don't I don't want to get
involved in a racial debate here but as
a privileged white male I want you to
know that I was triggered by the fact
that all those black people ignored the
fact that there was also half a white
face behind that turtleneck okay and how
do you think I felt
to not feel represented in that sweater
scandal is it [__] amazing this [__]
that just get like somehow gets traction
on social media you know what about the
[__] eight-year-old you know who
usually goes to bed at 3:00 in the
morning after sewing those [__]
things together in some sweatshop now we
had to stick around for an extra half
hour too so the extra [__] thread to
make sure it went up and over your mouth
right and then what happens everybody in
the first world country makes it all
about themselves and everybody forgets
about that little [__] kid there
right little [__] Joe Sixpack right I
don't know my wife is really into
fashion I so much of it it's just ugly
[__] you know and then they just have
some beautiful woman walk down the
runway like looking confident you know
but that one I swear to god that was
like something out of the Muppets wasn't
it I was like the dumb Donald [__] no
dump Donald had a hat pulled down over
his [__] I stand all the [__]
Cosby kids it was weird Harold one of
them had a sweater yanked up over its
face right over its Walt's a cartoon
hold on a second Fat Albert kids all
right who were they
let's see what did you have what did you
have images there was what was a weird
Harold no didn't one of them no I guess
they didn't there was Russell Rudy
Bucky bill dumb Donald weird Harold who
was the last one Mushmouth one of those
[__] cartoons had somebody with that
thing yanked up over its face I don't
[__] remember anyways that was a big
scandal everybody it was a big [__]
scandal you know but thank God people
spoke out and those sweaters will not be
mass-produced so whatever ones that they
have will now be thrown into the ocean
and we'll let the porpoises and dolphins
deal with it you know I mean it could
have kept a lot up half the lower half
of a lot of people's faces warm you know
they easily could have dyed it you know
made it a different color oven and then
what then you get Asians and Native
Americans start [__] complaining it's
just a bad idea I think that's what we
learned this week you know you can't get
mad at somebody for trying I mean it was
a turtleneck sweater what the [__] can
you do with it can you lower it a little
bit it's already been done mock
turtleneck sweater what do we do well
let's [__] let's keep it going
what do you think what do you think
underneath the mouth no right up and
over it that looks weird I'll put some
[__] lips on it you know if you're
sitting there going like bill who the
[__] talks about half a turtleneck
[__] blackface sweater for [__]
eight minutes well you know what it's
not football season anymore
football season is over then your New
England Patriots the other England
Patriots are the [__] champion you're
Boston Red Sox are the world
Series champion him it's [__]
unbelievable you know Bruins are playing
alright I don't know what's going on
with the Celtics somebody asked me today
on set to go a is Kyrie Irving gonna go
to the Lakers this kind of a room I
heard of room I have no idea all I know
is I don't think that they've been
playing as well as everybody thought
they were going to play so I have no
idea but I'm gonna try to check in on
that all I have to do now now that I'm
on the other side of that acting gig all
right all I got to do now you know I
keep doing the f is for family stuff and
at night I'm just gonna be running my
hour because I am taping my hour special
I kind of kept it under wraps as to
where I was taping it where I was
recording it and I feel like now is the
time you know cuz it's a very weird time
in comedy you hear that a lot now it's
not the time for those jokes I'm a white
woman who's not even funny and I'm
telling you that now is not the time for
that have you noticed that most people
who are saying what you should and
shouldn't be saying comedic ly are about
as funny as your average feature act
they're like middle act funny telling
like [__] really funny people what
they should be saying oh yes yes you by
all means who with your best joke you
just make me raise my eyebrows a little
bit like mmm yeah that was a funny
wasn't it by all means tell the world
what is funny I am going to be recording
my next hour special at Royal Albert
Hall in London that's right
I'm a traitor I'm going back to the
motherland yeah what the [__] I mean I'm
on my 6/1 I gotta try something
different I'm gonna go over there be
funny half of my [__] people will be
like I don't understand that and maybe a
little bomb for part of it we'll see if
it's funny anyways I'll be doing it at
Royal Albert Hall on Monday and Tuesday
March
what the [__] is that third and fourth
fourth and fifth fifth and sixth so I'm
gonna be doing a run of dates out here
[Music]
why I do the Borgata
what that [__] month is this oh that's
October why is this an October is the
last time I actually put anything in my
calendar October 29th I put in Jimmy
Kimmel how the [__] do I get out of this
click on this today click on today all
right here we go I'm sorry March yeah
March 4th and 5th alright so next week
on the 15th 16th and 17th I'll be in
Santa Barbara I'll be in Pasadena and
I'll be in Riverside California and then
I go to New York City on the 19th and I
do the Patrice O'Neal benefit and then
I'm in New York for a little bit doing
some spots out there and then I embark
on a little run of dates through the in
a great United Kingdom Great Britain
whatever the [__] you call it and then I
end up at I end up Royal Albert Hall and
then you have it and then when I get on
the other side of that [__] when I say
thank you goodnight on March 5th then
all I have to do is worry about wrapping
up the writing on season 4 of f is for
family and I don't have [__] until the
summertime and I'm just gonna be [__]
hanging in Cali doing you know getting
ready to do my new hour working mic
that's that's the game plan alright
because I love my daughter and I I don't
like leaving the way I used to you know
you know she she tried to get out of her
bed I saw it two months ago she was
swinging her leg up and over the the the
crib and my gut said you better put some
pillows down around the floor in case
she goes up and over and I just you know
I didn't listen to my gut like a [__]
idiot so I was coming home from me at
that amazing shoot that I was on that I
can't wait to [__] and tell you guys
about but I'm just not allowed to who's
so awesome
um but I came home last night and you
know after I got off set I never bring
my phone down to the set or a watch you
know cuz I don't want to know what time
it is cuz then it just makes it drag so
I just focus on whatever the [__] it is
I need to do and then I come walking out
at like 1:00 in the morning however it
works anyway some [__] coming back
you know I come outside and I get the
the pizza's here
I get this text message and it says
we're at the emergency room but blah
blah all his [__] [__] she fell out
of the bed and I'm like oh my god I'm
wiped out and I have to go to the
emergency room and my [__] tires has
a slow leak on the left side so I'm like
Greg it never ends
so I'm on my way there and it's so funny
like how my wife is wired and how I'm
wired like my wife is wired like a
normal caring human being and I'm like a
[__] lunatic I was raised the way I
was raised just in a different time so I
call her up she goes I go how is she
talking is she fine yes she's fine she's
joking around she's laughing she
actually didn't even cry until I came in
the room and cried and she sent me a
picture you know and I'm driving and I'm
looking at it you know like I shouldn't
be and I was just like yeah that she's
fine she's fine she's got a bump on her
head she's she's gonna be fine and bla
bla bla bla and we both had the exact
opposite she's like I'm not bringing her
home until a doctor looks at her I'll
never forgive myself and I'm like I'm
she's fine she's fine
so we walk up to the window to see where
we are it's like [__] 1:00 in the
morning or what a midnight I think and
there's all these [__] people there
with their kids and they're all
screaming and crying and they say were
16th in line it's just like they're not
gonna get to us still like [__] 3:00
in the morning
you know she's fine I literally I
remember being a kid swinging on these
ropes my other brother was on another
rope and we went right by each other and
then slammed into the backs of our heads
like slammed into each other like I saw
stars it all went white and I landed
facedown on the ground alright I was out
like I was conscious when I was on the
rope and when we hit I was unconscious
than I hit the ground and you know what
Mike dumbass did an hour and a half
later got right back on that [__]
thing and my other brother did too and I
remember the looks on our faces when we
passed each other going are we really
going to do this again and bam back of
our heads again saw lights knocked out
hit the ground you know and I was fine
so [__] it so I convinced her that she
was alright and she was alright but like
I've kind of realized in that like I
need to like kind of gauge that because
you know I came from a house where like
I had a ruptured appendix at one point
and my parents like you're fine you find
finally well they slice me open and I
don't like my old belly was just [__]
puss like Jesus Christ so whatever you
can take that rub some dirt on it too
far and then you can go the other way
where every time somebody has the
[__] sniffles you take him down to
the goddamn hospital you know what I
mean
but I think my wife was right to take
her down there but she was okay and she
woke up today and then not on her head
was a lot smaller and you know every kid
has to have their black eye picture you
know what I mean something that you did
so it was cool and I was so proud of her
that she didn't cry and she was she's a
little Tuffy you know she's a little
badass so anyways you know she's talking
up a storm and I got my little book and
I try to keep up on all the things that
she says you know you know it's funny
now is uh they have a park nearby and
like once a year they this little
carnival thing comes by and they have
like little pony rides and stuff so I
took her over there you know what's
going on like all the little kiddie
rides but there was awesome then and
then she saw the horses she's like horse
horse you know she knows how to make the
noise and [__] and they had the little
pony ride so you want to ride the horse
she goes yeah right right horse right
horse
she was all about it right and then paid
the ticket I'm going in I was like wow
man she's so brave you know she's so
brave right and uh and she was all about
it and right as I went to put her down
on it cuz I gonna put you down then they
like put this little safety harness and
then you was the parent walk along with
it right I went to set her down and the
second I started centered now she's
going no no no horse no horse so I
immediately got her out of there because
I didn't want to have her to have issues
with horses speaking of horses one of
the actors that I worked with them you
know all of this [__] I'm not allowed to
say knows a thing or two about horses
and I somehow asked them what does that
rode rode hard and put up wet what does
that expression me or you know there's a
couple of different ways to say it but
that's basically it rode hard and put up
wet he goes that's actually talking
about horses and it's kind of a you
insult somebody like Jesus Christ that
guy looks rode hard and put up wet and
it basically was I guess if you ride a
horse hard enough that it's it's
breathing hard and it's sweating and you
just were to then just walk it into a
barn
I guess they get like these stomach
cramps or something called colic or
something and they literally lay down on
the ground and they flip around or I
don't know what happens something gets
twisted up and they just [__] die so
what you have to do is after you wrote
them hard as you have to walk a horse
around until it slows slowly cools back
down again so it doesn't get those
cramps and if you put it in too early
and it lays down you gotta [__] get
that thing back up or it's gonna die or
whatever you know [__] horses man
they're really temperamental so I I had
no idea about that [__] so you know
these are the things that you learn
about while you sit now you know I
learned all of this [__] I learned about
you know there was an old school guy
there telling me about different actors
and how much of the how much land they
owed out owned out here you know like
this this actor went out and he bought
from this street to this street
which would yeah I mean if somebody went
to buy that same parcel of land today
out here in LA like I don't even ever be
a billion dollars of something and the
person bought it for like five grand and
then for the rest of their acting career
they just sort of slowly sold it off and
made all this money it's [__] like la
is one of the most amazing like historic
cities if you can somehow find out what
the [__] happened because God knows it's
not in any books because they don't give
a [__] out here they just [__] pave
[__] over it's one of the shadiest
goddamn plays awesome I [__] love it
but it is so [__] shady with you know
we used to have streetcars and trolleys
and all of this [__] [__] and then
one day you know that allegedly this
group of people got together you know
that was allegedly the automaker's and
in the Goodyear Tire people got together
and they bought up the trains and the
trolleys and they just ripped up all the
[__] tracks and turned it into this
[__] mess that it is now and I got
even Elon Musk digging underneath the
[__] you know he's already dug this
tunnel underneath LA and the people that
live in Beverly Hills are so [__]
rich they stopped Elon Musk who's
powerful enough to just start drilling
underneath the [__] city and they're
powerful enough to be a we do not want
those commoners taking public
transportation under because they know
what's going to happen is eventually
there is gonna be a subway stop in
Beverly Hills and they're like oh no oh
no no no we have not worked this [__]
hard in our lives to keep these [__]
to kick to get away from these [__]
people to have them then just get on
some magic carpet ride underneath the
[__] surface of the earth Tesla style
zero to sixty and one point something
seconds [__] you you're not doing it
right so they stopped it it's [__]
them but you can't do [__] in Beverly
Hills they're like [__]
you where they're dead like their own
city they do whatever the [__] they want
to do they [__] do it you know where
I live it's just like hey we like that
[__] you
bulldozers coming um anyways I got a
bunch of ad reads I got to do here so
let's see let's see if I can [__]
knock these out here Oh talk about how
every man looks better and feels more
confident when he puts on a suit well
yeah if your yeah everybody does cuz
you're dressing up you know I mean if
you're fat the sport coat really hides a
lot of pounds to a certain point you
don't I mean you know if you look fat in
a suit you just got to get on the
goddamn treadmill this is just tough
love okay lay off the sharise berries
okay start crushing the water is eaten
some salads you know what the [__] to do
it's gonna melt right off you that's it
you know cuz I got to tell you with
global warming I mean these [__]
polar bears are gonna start migrating
south and you know they used to eaten
fat seals so who the [__] you think
they're going after first all right and
yeah your big thighs rubbing together as
you're running in your [__] slacks
Indo Chino is the world's most exciting
made to menswear company they make suits
and shirts to your exact measurements
for an unparalleled fit and comfort
here's how it works
visit a stylist at your show at our
showroom and have them take your
measurements personally or measure at
home yourself shop online at Indo Chino
com
choose your fabric inside and out choose
your design customizations submit your
measurements with your choices relax
while your suit gets professionally
tailored and mailed to you in a couple
of weeks this week my listeners can get
any premium you know what they don't
make anymore you know those really shiny
[__] suits those good fella's suits
it's like you're wearing a suit that's
all you need to do what the [__] with
the shine on it this week mile is like
it was [__] laminated this week my
listeners can get any premium indochina
suit for three hundred fifty nine
dollars that's Indo Chino calm when
entering burb check
that's 50% off regular price for a
made-to-measure premium soup plus the
shipping is free
that's Indo Chino calm promo code bar
for any premium suit just 359 bucks and
free shipping incredible deal for a
premium made-to-measure suit
once you go custom you never go back
alright Robin Hood Robin Hood is an
investment app that lets you buy and
sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos all
commissioned free they strive to make
Financial Services work for everyone not
just the wealthy not intimidating
non-intimidating way for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence simple and
intuitive clear designed with data
presented in an easy to digest way other
brokerages charge up to $10 for every
trade but Robin Hood doesn't charge
Commission fees trade stocks and keep
all of your profit oh sorry does not
charge Commission fees trade stocks and
keep all of your profits easy to
understand chats and market day to place
a trade in just four taps on your smart
phone Robin Hood web platform also lets
you view stock collections 100 most
popular and entertainment social media
of female CEOs curated categories like
female CEOs if you're into that reverse
sexist [__] and analysts ratings of buy
/ hold / sell for every stock I tell you
guys better get on this pro-gun
Jesus Christ before it's over corrected
to the point we can't get now of a
sudden we've got to start marching in
the street you know we won't be doing
that dude it's not worth it just let
them have everything maybe then they'll
stop yelling at us learn how to invest
as you build your portfolio discover new
stocks track favorite companies with
personalized news feed Robin Hood is
giving listeners a free stock like Apple
Ford or sprint to help build your
portfolio sign up at billboard.com
that's capital B I ll be you are our dot
Robin Hood com that doesn't make sense
oh yeah it is Bill bird Robin Hood com
okay cool
you know I was thinking by the way I
didn't gloat about the Patriots
when in the Super Bowl because I still
can't believe they [__] did it but it
does make me feel good you know after
all the [__] giant fans gave me that the
New England Patriots now have more [__]
Tom Brady has more [__] rings than
the Giants and the Jets combined and the
Buffalo Bills
they have three NFL teams in the state
of New York and Tom Brady alone has one
more Super Bowls than those three teams
in their entire [__] existence so
I'll take those two losses Oh boohoo
we only went six and three sorry
just giving them fellow Patriots fans
some [__] ammo
alright 1-800 flowers by now most of us
have started racking our brains about
what Valentine's get Valentine's gift is
truly going to make her Day special it
just blows my mind that there's nothing
in here about guys you know all that all
these [__] women do is [__] how come
I can't announce on Monday Night
Football I don't know because you have
your own [__] holiday isn't that
enough for you
with 100 of flowers calm it's really not
that complicated roses from 1-800
flowers are a no-brainer right now when
you order early 1-800 flowers has
amazing deals on vibrant and romantic
Valentine's Rose's bouquets and
arrangements and more starting at just
30 bucks $29.99 there are so many
unbelievable deals hurry to 1-800
flowers now roses from 1-800 flowers our
hand-picked are picked at their peak
sorry and shipped overnight to ensure
freshness and and her amazement to
ensure freshness and her amazement
that's a weird sentence gorgeous
Valentine's bouquets and arrangements
starting at $29.99 is an amazing deal
but it won't last long
bouquet prices will be going up soon so
take advantage today pick your delivery
date and let 1-800 flowers handle the
rest when it comes to Valentine's you
don't settle for anything less than rose
Authority 1-800 flowers calm to order
valentine's day bouquets arrangements
and more starting at 29
and go to 1-800 flowers calm click on
the radio icon and enter Burpee you are
our order and save at 1-800 flowers comm
code burr how much they cost $29.99
alright let's look up steak in a [__]
day I always heard that that [__]
exists is that an actual day steak and a
[__]
God knows a progressive male will take a
veggie sandwich at a [__] hand job
let's see here steak in a [__]
all rights taking a [__] day stinking
a [__] day is a satirical holiday
creating the United States it's a male
response to Valentine's Day and
celebrated a month later on March 14th
on the day women are purport purported
to supposedly to cook a fillet steak
yeah good luck getting any woman under
the age of [__] 50 to do that the
women aren't to cook anymore I mean I
think they do it for themselves
and perform fellatio on a man in
response to postcards chocolate and
flowers given by men on Valentine's Day
the observance has no official status of
course being a popular internet meme
rather than an actual holiday but
various souvenirs and video clips have
been produced about it it was conceived
in 2002 by DJ Tom Birds II on W FNX
radio that's from Boston it has been
suggested that steak and a [__] day
is a backlash against the feminist
movement it has nothing to do with the
feminist movement has to do with the
weather [__] we sell it why do I only
have to buy [__] to celebrate that we're
together anyways oh oh who's coming in
my little Tuffy hey Mia just to let you
know in the official stake in a bj day
is March 14th beautiful just like that
see that I didn't have to may say
anything about feminism did I hi
gorgeous look at you you look like it's
week two of the playoffs
cherries berries Nia talk about your
plans for Valentine's Day this year what
would you do if you weren't
procrastinating I'm not procrastinating
I already have a reservation that my
wife made we're gonna go out and we're
gonna have some to eat share a personal
Valentine's Day story all right I always
tell this story one time I was dating
this woman and uh I didn't know what to
get her it was like my first girlfriend
and I went to the mall and they had
these polo shirts that were on sale so I
bought three of them for like golf
shirts that's what I bought a female and
she opened him up she was all excited
and she opened him up and she just went
like what what is this what who would
buy these and she got so mad at me she
started yelling at me and I was so
embarrassed that I literally sat down on
the bed like a scolded child and let her
yell at me for like three minutes before
I finally got enough self-esteem to tell
her to go to go to hell and then she
tried to backpedal that she actually
appreciated the fact that I went and I
got her gift like it's just like
sweetheart you're not buying me anything
I know this gift stinks but it's the
thought that counts right isn't that
what it is no it's the thought the
shininess and how much you spent yeah
they were ugly she was right she was
right
what do you do to look good on
Valentine's Day well I get a spray tan
for one I put on some me undies the Greg
looking for the Greg Louganis line I get
a spray-on like stubble on top of my
head put on a cumberbund and then I'm
out the door never never go wrong with
signature dip valentines strawberries
dipped in milk dark or white chocolate
goodness for any discernable palate
that's very progressive Nia notice the
white chocolate was last okay although
milk light-skinned there's still you
know still a little prejudiced er its
light-skinned too did it what do you
mean the color of it
come here
lemon can I ask you a question here were
you offended by that Gucci half a
blackface sweater I yeah yeah the whole
thing was just very strange to me
didn't you think it was a tribute to
Halfmoon cookies I did not think at all
no you can't it was black half a face
half black face black half face but I
felt triggered as a white man that they
didn't recognize the half a white face
that was there did you yes yes I'm sure
they will anyways dipped in milk dark or
white chocolate goodness for any
discerning palate she'll fall in love
with every bite top with decadent
toppings chocolate chips heart and
glitter sparkles perfect companion to a
candlelit dinner a bouquet of flowers or
a night out on the town arrived with
100% Sherry's can you say Sherry's
berries guarantee ships anywhere
nationally gives sweet something's to
your long-distance love Valentine's Day
is right around the corner I got you a
little Valentine's Day card you're my
buddy I got two by two now I got two
little girlfriends here go to Barry's
calm click on the microphone and enter
my code B you are are at checkout that's
BERR IES do T Co M Barrie's comm click
on the microphone and into the code bar
order today oh my god I still have one
more read here lastly but not leastly
all zip Rick wrote her she almost did it
wait zip she said zip she just says it
now say recruiter zip recruiter sends
you sends your job to over 100 of the
web's leading job boards but they don't
stop there with their powerful matching
technology old zip all their old zip
save recruiter
recruiter aisle maker says it with their
powerful machine to matching technology
separate cruelty scans thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them to apply to
your job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip is so
effective that 80% of employees who post
on say recruiter get quality candidates
through this site the first day and
right now my listeners can't rise say it
sees it recruiter and breakdown my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruited dot-com / / that zip recruited
comm / / / one more time that CIP
re-see are you ite are the smartest way
to hire all right listen to this lovely
music here and then we have another half
hour bonus material from a Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast to go by thank you to
everybody that worked with over the last
two weeks on this acting gig thank you
everybody gave me the opportunity I had
an unbelievably awesome time and I can't
wait for you guys to see and I can't
wait for you to tell you what it is and
when I do you're gonna be like oh my god
no you didn't I'm like yes hi f and did
I'll talk to you later
[Music]
where I am
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll know
well with whom you are
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday February 7th 2011 seven days into
February I'm actually doing this Sunday
night which is why all you [__]
in Europe actually got this [__]
podcast on Monday morning and everyone
across the states got it Monday morning
all right and even if you're on a
[__] oil tanker in the middle of the
goddamn Atlantic Ocean all right if you
didn't have to go off and swab the deck
or whatever the [__] it is you people do
out there you got it on a Monday morning
so I don't hear any goddamn bitching
this week well you could human you more
t-pod cuz it's my podcast you're
probably asking yourself why do I work
in a cubicle but beyond that you
probably ask yourself why did bill
actually do one on a Sunday evening so
it was actually there for his listeners
on a Monday maybe if he did that more
often he wouldn't be ranked number 52 on
iTunes according to one of my listeners
he let me know that he loved my podcast
and he thought that I should be ranked
much higher than number 52 well thanks a
lot thanks for letting me know how far
down the [__] ranks I am when you're
doing rankings who counts beyond the top
20 honestly coming in at number 73 mabel
millon filled with her how to make a pot
roast podcast every week she talks about
how to make a podcast you figured that
that would get boring way to go whatever
made-up name I said five seconds ago
um so I'm doing it because I'm [__]
busy today on Monday
believe it or not I actually I I booked
some acting work you know it's a great
thing you know when you were you know
being in this business you can watch
shows on TV and be fans of them and
actually low and behold one day
actually be on the [__] show and
since its inception this very few shows
that I watch every episode of and I just
have to tell you from day one I have
just loved that show Glee I mean it is
just phenomenal
you know the singing the dancing the way
they stole the Nellie Oleson character
from little house in the Prairie maid or
some old [__] with a [__] rape
whistle right it's a great goddamn show
and evidently they've been listening to
my podcast and they can see you know
they hear that I can belt out a tune you
know I could carry a tune and you know
I'm gonna go on this thing a little bit
Tony Bennett and I can I'm you know I'm
legally obligated to not say what the
entire episode is about so uh yeah
so I'm actually I'm taping an episode of
Glee this week and if you believe that I
got a [__] I got a I got a wind
screen to sell you um ya know I am
working this week as an actor I'm not
[__] telling you in which show okay
you figure it out alright there's only
600 channels you know how far into my
life do I have to let you but I am
working as an actor I'm [__] psyched
because my pilot for Comedy Central that
I was doing with another one of the
funniest [__] comedians I know did
not get picked up that's how my year
began began with a little bit of hope
for about two weeks and then the
industry grabbed one of my ankles and
then someone else he undersea grabbed
the other ankle and then they drove a
[__] TV emblem right into my ball bag
and said there you go bill have a great
[__] in 2011 you know when I was down in
the dumps for a couple two three days
but you know just like one of those old
one of those old [__] crooner songs
Jess what makes that little ol heck
think he can something-something in
something and everyone knows that you're
[__] but you don't got the balls to
kill yourself so you keep a dish
see can you believe I'm not on [__]
Glee um I can't - go [__] yourself you
figure it out when I'm on alright um so
anyways so this is the podcast so I was
gonna do it this afternoon
and I don't know they got away from me
and then I was like well the Super Bowls
today so I gotta make sure I do it after
the Super Bowl cuz I always talk about
sports and if you're someone who's hates
when I talk about sports you're really
gonna hate this podcast alright cuz I
gotta talk about a little bit there was
the [__] Super Bowl and you know you
showed up you sport hate and [__] didn't
you and you sat there and you ate the
[__] food didn't you then you ran
your mouth during the [__] game and
then you shut up during the commercials
right and then you gab with all the
chicks afterwards I thought that that
was a good one can you believe they pay
nine billion dollars a second right so
shut your face people who say they hate
[__] sports still show up to Super
Bowl parties alright if you do that
you're a punk all right when I say I
hate Sex in the City I don't show up for
the season finale you know I don't go to
the movie theater it's what I should do
when they make another one of those
horrific movies right do you know I
heard most of the budgets of those
movies is is actually dying the pubes of
the women who play those girls it's true
people out here in Hollywood man I have
the [__] trade magazines at my
fingertips I know people who are on
television they take that you get the
inside information here I can't believe
I'm ranked 52 with some of these gems
that I'm giving you this week it really
boggles my mind I'm gonna say I'm gonna
I'm gonna crack the top 50 this week I'm
gonna get to number 49 what do you think
about dead people um
I mean what the hell I'm talking about
this one's just gonna be all momentum
people all [__] momentum let's let's
talk about the Super Bowl shall we start
off right out of the gate my condolences
the Pittsburgh Steeler fans who was a
hell of a [__] game a little bit
boring in points but I think some of
that was had to do with both teams had
great defenses and the fact that Ben
Roethlisberger was wearing one sneaker
and one Moon boot or was that an UGG I
don't know what happened I don't know
what happened to that guy but I didn't
realize that he was so [__] up before
the goddamn game but my condolences and
congratulations to the Green Bay Packers
ladies and gentlemen their fourth Super
Bowl championship okay combining that
with nine NFL titles all right and three
league titles giving them an overall
total of 16 titles all right
nobody can [__] with that in
professional football in America all
right shut up you [__] over there in
Europe all right we call football
football over here even though we had
the brains to pick the [__] thing up
instead of skipping around [__]
unbelievable you go over there to Europe
they always give you [__] oh well you
know why you call it football my yelling
you you [__] off or shut up you don't
use your foot when you kick a field goal
and when you [__] kick off or you and
your punt all right
jesus [__] christ
supposed to call foot and hand balls out
what the [__] was become you don't call
it foot and head balls how come you know
call it that use your [__] head over
there too don't you all right there
smarty pants anyways sorry 16 [__]
titles all right that is their 16th
title so all you people there around the
[__] league who keep looking I don't
know and nobody I asked this question
why they don't count
NFL [__] titles and nobody gave me a
decent explanation they were these good
people [__] shut back then I got [__]
like that
I got [__] like all right
because did your demerger dumb [__] like
that right
that just made a lot of sports guys perk
they're [__] yourself yeah that is
right
dude he's white he's cuz the merger is
it is that why it is it's a [__]
stupid reason because nobody else did
that when they had a merger
you know the NHL had six teams for
[__] ever in 1967 they added the
expansion six they doubled the size of
their [__] league no other league has
done that in one year ever okay they
didn't tell Montreal and Toronto to go
[__] themselves with all their cups
Montreal used to win him back
you know when they used to play in a
pond the Stanley Cup was the size of
like a [__] shot glass they count
those the [__] Chicago Cubs have been
waiting since 1907 I don't [__]
understand it it's [__] it's
[__] okay
and later on in this podcast I'm you
know what [__] I'm gonna read it
right now
alright this is basically how it went
down alright I know why you all you
[__] sports nerds out there by the
way I want you guys to debunk my my way
of thinking here okay cuz you look at
the the Los Angeles Lakers two of their
NBA championships are not even they
weren't even one in the NBA they were
one in a league called the BVA
which then merged with some of it that
then became the NBA I mean you want to
talk about padding your [__] stats
you got I mean if the Lakers can get
away with that [__] and act like they're
one title away from the [__] Celtics
if they can get away with that horse
[__] with that hanky that they put up
with five [__] titles on it right
it's funny every other championship
banner they have hanging on their wall
it just says you know NBA champion 1980
NBA champion 1985 right they just have
that it's it's its own flag then they
got this one little [__] hanky okay
which should be a big slice of [__]
toilet paper that they got five [__]
championships on I think
Shemp played on one of those goddamn
teams it's [__] ridiculous but if
they can get away with that I'm telling
you I'm counting from here on out I'm
counting NFL titles all right I'm gonna
start a movement okay if I can't close
down the [__] Federal Reserve at
least I can make this thing right in
this goddamn country okay here's how it
goes
all right just if you want to know Green
Bay's on top all right this is how it
worked okay 1920s when the NFL started
all right from 1920 to 1932 they had the
league championship and it was
determined by team wins and lost
percentages with ties omitted and then
in 1932 because of a tie in the final
standings a playoff game was played to
determine the championship and from 1933
on that was called the NFL championship
game all right that's how it [__]
worked ok and all these teams including
the [__] Steelers played and played
back then so they had an opportunity to
win titles which they did not so here we
go here's how it goes down the most
successful teams from back then all
right
the Green Bay Packers they won nine NFL
championships and three league titles
for a total of [__] was that 93 the
112 um [__] it I didn't put these in any
sort of chronological order here so I
just got to read them the Colts went for
NFL championships alright and and then
another two Super Bowl so they got six
total the Giants one New York Giants New
York Football Giants went for NFL titles
plus three Super Bowls
so they got seven they got seven [__]
championships you know they're sitting
there walking around like they only got
three like they hang in there with my
Patriots they're not they got twice as
many as us plus one
Chicago Bears won nine NFL [__]
championships plus one Super Bowl for a
grand total of 10
the Cardinals I've lost this is why I'm
ranked number 52 I've lost so many
listeners at this point I don't give a
[__]
Chicago Cardinals which then became the
st. Louis Cardinals which then became
the Arizona Cardinal
they won one league in one NFL title and
if you want to go to an Arizona
Cardinals game and if you want to
[__] chant a year at those [__]
retired George McGovern Republican [__]
1947 that's the year you want to chant
at them 1947 all right the Lions won
four NFL championships I forgot when
that last one I have the wrong year
written down was 1950 something
Cleveland Rams which then became the LA
Rams in 1946 and then became the st.
Louis Rams in nineteen [__] 95 I know
I sound like the Rain Man they have won
three NFL championships plus one Super
Bowl for a grand total of four here's my
favorite one the Cleveland Browns they
won for NFL titles all right and before
that they won for all American Football
Conference titles all right and there
were three teams that were in the All
American Football Conference that merged
with the NFL in 1950 and I'm not
counting those championships by the way
the All American Football Conference I
wouldn't count those because that wasn't
in the NFL that would be like the Lakers
counting those B be a [__]
championships the all-american football
concert conference existed from 1946 to
1949 they had four championship games
and the [__] Cleveland Browns won all
four they dominated that league that
league merged with the NFL in 1950 and
they took three teams with them the
Browns the Colts and the 49ers
all right we're continuing and we got a
couple more here the Philadelphia Eagles
one three three NFL titles last ones
1960 that's what you want to chance at
those angry bastards and then good luck
to you after that 49ers 1-0 and five
Super Bowls Steelers 1-0 NFL titles and
have six Super Bowls so there you go for
all you sports nerds out there that's
the deal all right so I don't want to
[__] hear anything this any acting
like those things don't count they do
come that was the best of the best back
then and they went through the same
[__] as every other [__] league
with oh but they didn't let black guys
play back then so what so what every
other sport counts those [__] things
I didn't what the hell my goddamn point
was but uh you know what I did want to
read to continue with I'll get back to
the stats in a minute but can I actually
bring up something here about the Super
Bowl what was going on with the
beginning of the game this year with
those [__] whaling [__] that they
brought out to sing every song that that
ever about America you know they brought
that chick from [__] Glee who tried to
make America the Beautiful sexy or
singing Amazing Grace Amazing Grace they
got their little as they slide into the
[__] line all right
she should have been booted right in the
box and Christina Aguilera right then
she comes out with her boos face see
that's why I'm been laying off the booze
man that's it right there that's not
baby weight all right
that chick likes her bear she came out
there and I loved her though I like how
she sort of freestyled the national
anthem you know what I mean who can
honestly remember those words unless
you're singing it was somebody else it's
a really difficult thing to do she was
just out there let's go to the ball and
something else American and the flag was
still there
[Music]
um so anyways I mean how long did that's
you know what kills me was I I looked on
my cable thing and it said Super Bowl
pregame all right out here the Super
Bowl comes on at 3:00 in the afternoon
so I see from [__] like 12:00 noon to
like three is the pregame I don't want
to see that [__] I don't give a [__] I
don't give a [__]
I don't really sees people break down
the game the keys to the game I could
give a [__] all right they're never
right I don't give a [__] I just don't
care so I'm like okay the game
starts at 3 and then I go to put it on
and what do they have more of this pomp
and [__] circumstance and I don't
like how they gotta sing like 58 songs
about [__] I understand that it's in
America it's obnoxious Jesus Christ with
the [__] songs and then they gotta
make them laugh every time you think
that done they gotta add a couple huh to
the [__] line and you just sitting
there yeah I don't get it it's the most
important game of the NFL season and
they just dragged out one douche bag
after another it has nothing to do with
the game by the time the game starts
it's like I don't even give a [__] you
know but at least Deion Sanders dressed
up for the game Jesus Christ man that
guy really was showing his age how can
you be that flashy and [__] up that bad
you know what I mean it was like he
picked out that shirt and tie and right
before he went out there somebody
spilled coffee all over it I think he
had like a white suit and then he just
went to the nearest like tire salesman
hey you know once you give me she gave
me this brown suit I'll just put it over
this is candy cane striped shirt with
the [__] tie um anyways let me let me
get let me get to some stats for the
past [__] week here I actually I
actually took the Steelers in the over
just because I knew everyone was gonna
pick the Packers in the under I didn't
even know what the [__] was I lost 25
bucks that was my big thing you know
what this is the first time the [__]
podcast officially hit a goddamn speed
bump here all right bill I'm emailing
you so we didn't my stats last week how
many times I said [__] on the podcast
this was pretty staggering so bill I
email I'm emailing you to inform you
that I served as your personal
statistician statistician during your
previous podcast on January 31st 2011 I
documented each and every time you said
the word [__] are some variants of the
word I must say you're in a goddamn
league of your own thank you you're the
podcasting f bomb dropping equivalent of
[__] Wilt Chamberlain in 1962 all
right let's get to anyways
he said it's kind of ironic that I'm
patting you on the back in a way for
this feat because the through a little
research I discovered that you used to
pride yourself on a clean bit during the
early stages of your career yeah I did I
had to figure out if I could be funny
without cursing and once I proved to
myself that I could I was then free to
be myself who's a cosy smug [__]
um despite that fact he said it's
obvious that you're off the wagon and
[__] [__] up on a whole nother level
nowadays your numbers are [__]
astonishing you might as well throw on
some red red leather pants and a gold
chain cuz your vote your vulgarity is
reminiscent of Eddie Murphy's in the
1980s you transparent bastard now lists
a few of your milestones below and then
elaborate on just how revolutionary and
earth-shattering your last podcast was
all right this is actually I was kind of
amazed by this first usage of the word
[__] occurred 38 seconds into the
podcast you hit the century mark 17
minutes in this stat is mind-boggling to
me it took you little ol little over the
equivalent of one quarter of football to
drop a hundred f-bombs you did this
almost leisurely - you're a [__]
juggernaut I can only imagine the damage
you you do while watching a real quarter
of football all sauced up on the juice
so anyways I guess I last week my
podcast was 73 minutes and I said the
f-word 347 times Jesus Christ you used
roughly a year's worth of cuss words in
a little over an hour come on dude if
you use the f-word there's no way you
say it once a day
all right that's four point seven five
three uses per minute you make Andrew
Dice Clay and Bob Saget stuff look pg-13
I'd argue that first half breakdown in
the first thirty six and a half minutes
I used it two hundred and ten times in
the second half 137 look at that I
slowed down after the all-star break
everybody thought I was gonna be the
first guy to break 400 and I didn't
so this guy actually made a graph of it
first of all if I can figure out how to
download this I download it I can't find
it in my computer he has the marker with
next to his the Sharpie with his
headphones and all that like he's
counting off days in prison 345 little
slashes there groups of 5 and then he
compared me to some of the most vulgar
movies of all time uses per minute I
beat out casino Martin Lawrence live
Goodfellas menace to society Eddie
Murphy delirious The Big Lebowski and
pulp fiction and then total count of
movies I came in second behind casino
but in my defense that's like a two hour
movie so [__] them there you go is that
enough stats for you in the first 20
minutes Jesus Christ gonna be ranked
like 700 at this point um so anyways
what the hell is my my week like I got
over my road AIDS just to let you guys
know I got over it
I I don't know it just kept getting
worse too like Friday and it's all
because I forgot my vitamins I told you
guys I booked some acting work right for
tomorrow so what do I do I'm getting
ready for the Super Bowl okay my
Patriots got beaten by the Jets so I
don't give a [__] I know I said I
wouldn't tracks Rex Ryan but for some
reason I couldn't resist and I had to
watch his post game lost to the Steelers
speech and it just you know it just
drove me nuts he was like you know you
know a lot of people are gonna want to
criticize this and they can but you know
they don't have they don't have any
right it's just why don't they have a
right he's like this team's been through
a lot yeah you created most of it with
your [__] talking you [__] talked the
whole work the whole [__] year and
you'll get said you were gonna win the
Superbowl you wrote at the side of the
bus and you didn't why do you feel
people don't have a right to give you
[__] at that point it's [__] annoying
in your gear yet here I'm gonna have the
shame it's going to be the shame
I'll have the same goal you know what I
hate about that [__] is one year he's
finally gonna win it and be like dude
what'd I say
what'd I say you know what you said Rex
the same thing you say every [__] day
so stop acting like you called it I
can't stand that [__] that drives me
nuts when you're [__] wrong just be a
man about it be like yeah I talked a lot
of [__] this year and I was [__] wrong
so I'm here to take my medicine you know
such a [__] fat [__] anyways so I'm
getting ready for the get ready for the
Superbowl and I don't give a [__] writes
the Steelers hits the Packers I don't
give a [__] I give a flying [__] about
this game you know I don't I don't care
neither one of those teams have ever
done anything really did the Patriots I
guess the Packers beat us in 97 but who
gives a [__] we weren't supposed to win
that game that was Brett Favre remember
that young Brett Favre he had brown hair
and then he he threw that first
touchdown passed and he took his helmet
off and ran and went over to the
sideline you remember that and they
actually had to make a rule that you
can't do that anymore because he was so
blatantly trying to get some sort of
national commercial yeah he just loves
the game that guy just loves playing a
game oh how funny was it when the big
lebowski guy with the [__] most
insane mustache ever when he did those
voiceovers people of Pittsburgh are you
tired of them acting like people still
work in steel mills out there you know
cuz I have to admit as as a fan from
Boston any time they do anything about
New England they show a lighthouse and a
[__] lobster fisherman and I lived
there for 27 years and I never met
anyone who worked in a [__]
lighthouse ran a lighthouse or even
worked on a [__] lobster boat nobody
you know and I didn't like clam chowder
I thought it looked like it just looked
like a curdled milk get out look gross I
didn't like it but yeah they're just
sitting there talking about Pittsburgh
oh this burg Pittsburgh's a tough town
built on stale
when you're Pittsburgh if you get hit by
a bus your mother calls you a [__]
right I [__] hate that [__] and then
they go up Green Bay Green Bay's the
same [__] as itself [__] place
people used to pack [__] over Green Bay
the Great Bay when there's packing to be
done you don't have to look too far to
find somebody to pack something you know
I just wish they would be more honest
you know this place used to have a bunch
of steel mills now they all closed down
they're all rusted in half of got turned
into malls now there's a bunch of half
[__] sitting in cubicles looking at
spreadsheets up in Wisconsin you got a
bunch of fat [__] that are the goddamn
[__] pasty and they got red [__] on
their face from the goddamn cold ain't
[__] been packed up here since 40 years
before and after they're a bunch of
cheesy fat [__] this is all that God
for the love of God let the Packers win
why don't they do [__] like that could
they do that then I'd watch it then I
wouldn't have it on [__] mute you
know it'd be a nice break between
whaling [__] singing songs about
America that diva [__] ah just Christina
Aguilera how about some p90x baby
good lord I don't give a [__] she had a
kid you're still in your 20s go hit the
[__] treadmill what happened you know
that's the danger that's the danger you
know that's why I'm so glad you know I
had a choice at some point in my career
to become a sex symbol and I was just
like you know what I'm not gonna do it
you know cuz there's only one way to go
just go down I did people I actually had
the opportunity to become Hollywood's
first male redheaded sex symbol all
right I know what you're thinking what
about that [__]
pasty freckled ass [__] who was on on
NYPD Blue [__] his whole career up
what about that guy I have been in this
business since before he [__] up his
career do you understand that people do
you realize on March 2nd I am gonna be
celebrating my 19th year of traveling to
strip malls making people laugh giggle
that might little wacky view of the
world
it's pretty [__] depressing I can't
believe it man
I might went out when I was when I was a
[__] kid when I got in this business
when I looked at some of the men doing
it 17 years I used to look at him like
dude [__] hang it up cuz it is over
it is [__] over you are not making it
buddy
okay maybe that's why you're sweating
right through your [__] sport coat
Jesus I started in 1992 that's right so
if there was a 17 year [__] veteran
not Jesus I got new math no that would
be there that would mean they started in
1975 if I worked for somebody in 1992
and they started in 1975 I would [__]
be like dude wow what was that like what
was it like you know drive into you know
I don't know what what the [__] you guys
did back then flying on planes with
propellers what what happened and now I
don't know what happened I'm 19 years
into this [__] and I realized now why
those guys 17 years in didn't quit
because when you have a 17 to 19 year
gap in your resume you know from the
last time you actually had a day job
excuse me um yeah you're done
no no what's gonna hire what didn't even
hire me to do sell cars what he been
doing since 1992 I was kind of I was
kind of a [__] I have three and a half
years of podcasts where I say some of
the most horrific [__] ever there was
any sort of corporate job right why the
hell would I want to work for them
anyways you know you become part of the
murder or whatever the [__] it is that
you're doing
there's always some sort of killing
going on when you work for corporation
you know it is
if you follow it and then you sit there
lying to yourself well you know I just
shine the gun I don't pull the trigger
you know ah he's a [__] worst um yeah
so I've been doing it 19 years that
there's really no turning back for me
and if for some reason the bottom falls
out I don't know what I would do I have
no I no [__] idea what I would do
which is why I don't think about this
type of [__] so I got 19 [__] years
in that's unbelievable to me I remember
when I hit 10 years and I was like Jesus
I just look at guys like 12 13 years in
when I had like eight go man they've
been doing it a while they have to make
it now they better make it now that is
[__] over so I don't know what I'm
saying you know which probably brings up
the question like bill do you think you
made it like what is it that makes you
feel like you meant you know what I
think I did I did write the [__] I
didn't have look I must [__] see
student okay so my goals aren't that
high I look at it like I made it I book
Glee this week oh [__] I gotta get a
puppet people I gotta do it man I gotta
make it I have one year to make it if I
don't [__] make it in the next year
20 [__] years in I'll tell you right
now you better build an extension to
your goddamn cubicle people cuz I'm
showing up now I can't do it I left the
program I'm like [__] whatsit Marlon
Brando's character in a pop apocalypse
now I'm all the way up the river it's
over alright I got a head on the stick
there's no [__] way there's no way I
could ever go back and get a real job
I'd have to have a kid and be like I'm
doing it for him or her right that's the
only way I could there's no [__] way
I could go in there and have somebody Oh
bill um I noticed you came in at 9:08
this morning
did you did you notice anything else
like how [__] up that Thai issue I'd
like immediately I would just go to that
actually I wouldn't yeah look at me
trying to paint myself like I'm a badass
I wouldn't I'd be like oh yeah so I
immediately go into that time uh traffic
and you know just become that guy and
hate myself and take it out on some
sweet lady at work next to me who's been
with the company for twenty five years
you know she's never missed a day
yeah it's cuz she's stealing from the
company you dumb [__] uh she's too
afraid to take a day off you ever think
about that
alright let's get let's get to some
topics here so once again
congratulations to the Green Bay Packers
all right up there in Green Bay when you
live off one of the Great Lakes you
better take your dick and wrap it around
your balls cuz there ain't no room for
[__] sorry um I better save my voice
see this is this is a type of
self-sabotage that's been part of my
career for last 19 years I do [__] like
this I should you know I should just be
thinking to myself and say [__] you guys
and the 52nd ranked podcast on iTunes
I should be resting up on my voice
that's what I should be [__] doing but
I'm not I'm not this is this is this is
what I you know I don't know why I just
I thought I this is my thought I had so
I'm getting ready to superb alright I
don't give a [__] about either tape now
so I'm gonna go make a couple of burgers
so I've been using this natural goddamn
charcoal which is great doesn't have
that chemical [__] on it you know you
know that [__] when you're really hungry
if you use that that match light stuff
and you throw the patty on too early if
you taste the lighter fluid fluid in
your burger so I'm using the natural
stuff which takes longer to light and
it's more of a pain in the ass when you
get down to the bottom of the bag the
pieces are too [__] small or you got
one giant piece so I take out one giant
piece it's like I'm not breaking this
[__] up long story short I
couldn't get any sizzle on my grizzle
alright dad I'm starving so my girl is
like well why don't we just make it why
don't we just make it on the on the on
the stovetop it's like
I'm like cuz I'm a man that's why
because I can't admit defeat
I can't admit the fact that what I'm
doing I don't know what the [__] I'm
doing right now all right so I just
added more fuel to the damn fire so then
I throw these [__] patties on is what
I do and I make these two [__] things
I melt the cheese and I think
everything's going on right now but I'm
doing it like I had some sizzle on my
grizzy zl-- you like that that's right a
little hip-hop not for this week and
evidently I didn't so I you know rather
than cutting in and making sure
everything was done it didn't I just
take these [__] off okay and
then like the size you know twice the
size of McDonald's burgers they're just
little ones I don't give a [__] right so
I take it off the grill
I put what I put on my burgers which is
just ketchup and pickle I keep it
[__] simple all right slice the
[__] in half and I look in the
inside of it looks like raw meat and
immediately my brain goes don't eat that
[__] okay you're gonna get a coli you
have to take Glee tomorrow
how can you sing with a deadly virus
inside of you you just got overrode AIDS
okay let's not head a coli to this but
what do I do I don't give a [__] I just
eat the goddamn thing you know eat the
[__] thing I smell like smoke like
I'm taking a shower and I'm in there
just waiting for this feeling of [__]
death you know fortunately it never hit
me but you know what why why would I do
something like that self sabotage stupid
you know that's why I never booked an
episode of Caroline in the city I mean I
booked one but I you know I [__]
night I got salmonella all right you
know what people that story wouldn't
know where I'm apologize so you know I
think it's time to bring a guest onto
the show I'm gonna hit pause here in the
recording cuz I got to set up the
microphone we're gonna bring my lovely
girlfriend in and she's going to
contribute on this week's version of is
it racist racist racist yes ladies and
gentlemen it is time once again for is
it racist racist
yes this time this time I am joined by
my lovely girlfriend Nia how are you
sweetheart I'm great sweetie how are you
I'm fantastic let's not be too nice to
each other okay because of my listeners
you know I find out this week I'm ranked
52nd on the podcast on iTunes out of how
many
like 63 I don't know how many there are
I know everybody has a party you're
getting there baby alright well here we
go we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
bring you in here and and now you know
you got to hand it to me huh for what
well you know I booked Glee this week oh
that's right no I'm so excited about
that no I'm nervous about my dancing no
we've been working on your pas de Bouree
is so I have felt pretty good this guy
wrote from our BYU are you familiar with
BYU Brigham Young University
you know those people right yeah they're
Wilding out out there right Wow and out
well and out they have like 12 wives
each skirts down to their ankles skirts
down to their ankles and they don't all
ours up to their chin yeah and they're
all virgins before they get married
vaginally right and then they just have
anal that's cute everybody that is Salt
Flats and you've seen that [__] city
that state all right BYU is this racist
he says bill is it racist to root for
BYU this is the college because they
have the best scorer Glen Falls finest
white boy they start for white kids in
total and our eighth in the note in the
nation because I do so evidently this
guy's white and he's rooting for this
white basketball team basically they
start for white guys and one of the
highest number one scorers in the league
is white and he's white is it right is
it racist racist because
why don't you just use the effect of
your GarageBand because it takes too
much [__] time Wow
plus I think it sounds better is it
racist that a white guy just wait for a
white people on a white team full of
white people doing white things by
having white beliefs no it is not racist
it's not racist okay and why because it
has nothing to do with race it's not
like he's saying because everything well
it's not like he's saying like you know
[__] black people they can't play
basketball right it's white people white
people own that's what it it you know
that it's not like that he just likes
the white people i what I think I think
if you if you're people traditionally
suck at something more have been
prevented from doing something then it's
okay for you to root for your guy okay
now that is nobody prevented what people
from playing we just sort of sucked at
it for a while I don't understand why
because we can't jump no no no I don't
understand why he thinks that that would
even be in the racist category because
we get in trouble for everything because
he's rooting for he's like I like this
team I'm rooting for them but I don't
want people to think I'm racist no it's
just because look if you're [__] 30
years are younger you don't even
remember white people doing a forty
years are younger you don't remember us
dominating any [__] sport
other than hockey right alright and
we're starting to creep in on that a
little bit black people is like it's
like LeBron when LeBron talks about the
scoring title yeah remember well you
don't watch sports but like LeBron was
just like one time they were asking him
about the scoring title they like you
know what do you know about Kobe and he
said look if I wanted to if I wanted to
I could win that [__] thing but he's
trying to like with like I look it I
look at hockey the same way like if
black people wanted to if you wanted to
we could dominate hockey you could I
don't know you know I mean how do we
don't like the fouls
how many more sport examples do you need
more sports do you have to [__] take
over before you just sort of realize you
know
you're killing it yeah now that that is
not racist yeah I don't think it's races
either because we've been getting dunked
on for [__] yeah
oh yeah you wants the rule for white
people that's not racist yeah okay all
right so there we go that's that's the
first one all right next one this is
this is a good one here racism or
ethnicity
I did this after the Super Bowl I got
e.coli and road AIDS here bill I've been
listening to your recent podcast about
racism had a few questions pop in my
head why do they call your background
your ethnicity example Spanish
african-american Chinese but why when we
tease someone's ethnicity
it's called racism maybe it should be
called Ethne store Ethne sysm i don't
know what he's basically saying there is
why if i guess if you go I don't like
those German [__] why would
that be considered racist and she would
that be that would be more of an ethnic
thing because they are they're a certain
brand of white people I honestly don't
know you don't I got a question no no I
think I'm a little stumped too like I
don't know that I know the difference
necessarily between ethnicity and race
all right well why don't I know that I
don't know why well tell me okay well
race is like like would be like there we
go
black people white people like look
people from okay people from England
France Germany all them those are white
people okay Missa tee but like your
ethnicity is German Irish German Irish
Scottish English and French my ethnicity
is like African and like a small small
drop of Native American or stay you go
okay so what's your race your race is
black like yes basically or African
American whatever the [__] you fill out
right okay thanks I guess I guess he's
saying a lot of times that I don't what
the [__] he's saying I think he's saying
like if someone like was given [__]
about Irish people they say it's racist
or something like that oh you're making
fun of the ethnicity got it you know cuz
you're not trashing all white people
right you're just you're just
complaining about a certain ethnicity
right as opposed to entire race of
people
Caucasian versus Irish yeah I'm trying
to get some fire on this topic well yeah
you know what is fear you get to [__]
artist you disagree with all of this
[__] I'm not agreeing with it I just I
don't know why they I don't know why
that that's called that either well you
thought my older Asian game that I play
you said that that was racist right yes
how is that racist not the old part
that's ageist right but yeah cuz you
said that all Asian people can't drive I
know I didn't yes you did what did I say
that you always say that I didn't I said
if somebody [__] up in front of me
those are the two I'm guessing you don't
see halat's or Asian you don't see how
that you're you're taking like one group
of people and stereotyping them yes I'm
definitely stereotyping them oh I see
but what you're saying is that you're
not like I'm not saying Asians are bad
people that uh yeah saying that they
can't drive so your stereotype no
intersection makes a [__] u-turn on a
highway if it's not an 85 year old guy
if you had to take your life savings I'm
not even saying it's gonna be an Asian
guy so but if you had to bet right and
if your life was on the [__] line
telling you I know the notion so in the
grand question of is Bill burr racist
against Asians I would say no but he
does stereotype them really really badly
and whose fault is that yours no it
isn't do you think I just pulled that
out of it look if someone said that
white people can't jump do you think
they just pull that out of their [__]
ass duh I mean [__] white guys do
- one how many six foot ten inch white
guys do you got a watch slam the ball
into the front of the rim
and almost dislocate their shoulder
trying to [__] break away before you
can say why people can't jump did you go
ahead you two in you go on YouTube and
you'll see some white dudes doing some
[__] yeah white people could do place
right you think you're think they're the
exception and not the rule I'm just
saying that if somebody said to me who
wasn't white said white guys can't jump
and they can't [__] dance I'm really
not gonna get into what he did the baby
I'm sure Donny Osmond can cut a [__]
rug with John Travolta or whoever the
[__] you are Kevin Federline he was a
dancer that doesn't count before he
became a me but it wasn't though he he
hung out with black people
he had cornrows yeah and you like to
bang girls doesn't count that doesn't
count
Timberlake stole Michael Jackson's voice
and all the [__] that Michael Jackson
actually stole from mimes and hip-hop
dancers and James Brown James Brown I
don't [__] I'm just talking [__]
you all right well I see the distinction
but it's still it's still wrong what is
wrong it's wrong of you to stereotype
Asian people yeah I'm not [__]
hurting anybody
we get started it started off it's a
joke in the [__] car I know that you
see a life just don't stand up right now
unless you're gonna use that finger I
suggest you put it away oh [__] that's
for like second grade what do you have
on boots right now it's really annoying
why are you in your underwear you want
to talk [__] cuz it's [__] 10 o'clock
at night I'm in my own goddamn bedroom
if you were going outside that would
make sense you're wearing tighty whities
but they're black these are like the
snug ones they're like biker sure I said
they cut my balls they make them feel
good
what's wrong with that you said you like
these and you were wearing your boss and
Bruin should I do like
yeah but you got a lot of nerve standing
up pontificating in your underwear
why Kariya's it shows you how passionate
I am about my opinions I want to bribe
one of your listeners so like send me
something like an Amazon gift wish like
a what gift wishlist and I'll send them
a picture of you right now as you are
meals they don't need it at this point
with technology they just take my head
stick it on somebody anyway so that's
which is what they're all gonna do now
thanks thanks me anything else you'd
like to add
you guys will somebody please do that
make a composite of that and email it to
Bill
okay you know what this is all about is
I have too much control in the
relationship right now so this is what
you're doing you try to get my listeners
to turn on me is that what it is divide
and conquer
alright this is why I brought that [__]
up this way I stood up my underwear and
I started pointing at you raising my
voice the [__] are we talking we talked
about that older Asian thing Yeah right
and it was one of those we were in the
[__] car and you've you've admitted
in the car you like Jesus Christ there's
something to this game when it was a
little odd that's the closest I'm ever
gonna get you admitted to your [__]
because the best one was well there's an
old Asian guy that's what we came up
like that was hitting like the green
double zero and [__] out roulette you
had to call old Asian well it's rude I
have is gonna sound terrible but I have
Asian friends so I don't want people to
think that I sort of why they haven't
che Bobby Lee I love Bobby Lee you don't
love Kevin Shea I don't know him really
Bobby Kevin Shea is like the angry Bobby
Lee okay
yeah got it yeah Bobby Lee's anger is
just somewhere hidden in there Jesus
Christ yeah yeah you know what this is
this is right here this is why you know
when you wanna break balls you gotta
hang out with other guys because the
woman's gonna ruin it
what if y-you want to bring in a little
another mini bill burr and here just
your own opinion regurgitated over and
over again won't you get with like audio
of a crowd applauding underneath it
there's always write another or give me
another is a racist all right well I
have to look up one you real Oh do you
realize I said the F word three hundred
forty seven times that it is incredible
even for you
really Jesus Christ you're just really
abandoned me aren't you I'm not but
that's excessive Nia this podcast is
excessive that beard is excessive you're
the one who told me to [__] grow it I
love it
he told me to grow a goddamn beard yeah
I like it and guess what you got a part
on Glee because of it that's right all
right now these are the ones I'm just
grabbing these I don't know where okay
okay and this this was your [__] idea
too cuz some of these get crazy all
right bill no no I'd like to get your
fault I'd like to use your is it racist
segment to get a ruling on a dispute
between myself a white guy and some
friends the issue involves the issue in
question revolves around a particular
Halloween costume of mine a few years
back you chose this one near here we go
anyway anyone who's been to Vegas knows
about the porn slappers that clog up all
the sidewalks on the strip I guess those
are the guys who hand out the Flyers I
guess I have no idea
so calls because as they're handing out
the stripper our US business cards they
give him a quick snap on the handle oh
yeah got them in your face okay as if
having full-color porn pushed on you
while trying to walk down the street
wasn't enough I guess they deem it
necessary to violate your auditory
senses as well well they got to get you
to pay attention all right during a
routine trip that reminds me of
something I'm sorry that slapping of the
car that reminds me I remember we went
to Jumbo's clown room and that girl when
we thought when we first went in there
the stripper was like super friendly say
hi as you walk in and then occasionally
you'd hear like like a clapping noise
really lettuce
somebody that shot and it was her
clapping her boot her stripper boots
together trying to get your attention
like because the room was too quiet and
we're paying attention to her it was so
pathetic in there and all of a sudden it
sound like a gunshot that was that
stripper yeah exactly
anyway she didn't like say I'm never
dancing again she just stopped dancing
she crawled over on her hands and knees
to her purse light on her stomach pulled
her phone out inside texting on stage
music still going titties out with the
thong on but the best part was she she
danced the whole first song yeah and
didn't make one dime it was slowly
coming down the pole
and then whatever the hell it wasn't it
landed on her back not one guy mom she
was horrific she was ugly too and the
next song started and she was just
laying there yeah she didn't answer the
bell like a fighter
quit on the [__] stool anyways this
goes continue where during a routine
trip to Vegas note of scene yeah how he
paints himself as somebody innocent you
know I thought it would be funny to
dress up as a porn slapper for Halloween
so while there I collected a sizeable
stack of the previously mentioned cards
when I returned home I had a fluorescent
pink stripper direct to you shirt made
had it made up and assembled with other
components to create what I considered
to be an authentic reproduction is this
gonna end with him in blackface
it's gonna end with him in Mexican face
okay whatever cuz that's all the guys
seem to be like Hispanic I know where
this is going
here's one the train went off the tracks
and a claim that the costume became
racist right my completed costume
consisted of a straw cowboy hat mm-hmm
short black wig Brown facial makeup a
large mustache yes stripper direct shirt
so Navy Dickies and tennis shoes
basically if Pancho Villa had to get a
second job to pick up a little cash on
the side that's what I end up looking
like now did any of my so-called white
friends mention that this costume might
be racist during the construction phrase
are they so-called white or they
so-called friends
call white branch of course not they
didn't say Oh basics those white friends
didn't say [__] but the second I'm out
on Halloween night suddenly I'm
surrounded by spokespeople for the
anti-defamation league dude what the
[__] did you do this my stance and all
this was yes that the costume was
probably racially insensitive but it was
not done to be malicious I was just
shooting for authenticity and therefore
it wasn't racist my friends claimed that
it was blatantly racist the friends
didn't say [__] we were not trying to
step away call white friend so call
white bread can I please get your
opinion on this all right here's my
question did he have to he could have
done that entire costume without the
blood say brown face without the brown
face and people would have gotten it cuz
he'd be handing out those think you'd be
saying he'll be like Oh cuz everyone's
gone to Vegas everyone she knows I went
to Vegas I brought you back a stack of
those [__] cards so I thought it was
funny so people would have gotten it so
it does seem a little excessive to add
the brown face well he is he's dipping
his toe in the racist pond
I do not think that this person is a
racist human being I don't think he's
like he thinks Mexican people or better
actually they shouldn't I shouldn't even
say Mexican they could be Peruvian
whatever I don't think he things are bad
but he definitely dipped his toe in
because there was really no need to go
that far
he could have done the entire thing and
everyone would have gotten it all right
this is what I said he didn't need brown
face is what I say I say this isn't
racist I say what he's guilty of is not
knowing that he was gonna be called a
racist because if every [__] due to
the handing those things out that
weekend was Mexican and looked like that
yeah
and he went all out yeah to try to look
like that all he's guilty of is having a
[__] kick-ass costume
all right and if the Wayans brothers can
make white chicks that [__] horrific
horror that I [__] saw nothing I
didn't see the movie but I just like was
so [__] weird that that just got to
transvestite II for me when he took his
foot out and had it on the table it just
really was [__] I didn't understand
how we're supposed to believe that
everyone in the movie doesn't realize
that it's black people who white
another man I'm like do you people
really believe that this is an actual
white person like they're talking to
other white people like it doesn't look
weird and this is my thing if you can
[__] do that okay which I get I get
the rules our [__] different cuz all
the [__] that's happens okay so
that's one of those things where he's
guilty of light like a white person who
doesn't mean anything bad but says you
people are you guys right and then has
to be like what I didn't know I didn't
[__] know so I wouldn't say that
that's that's that's not racist it's
just but your friends are [__]
sellouts who I think they did it on
purpose I think they were like oh this
is gonna be good I think they wanted him
to get called out if they did it on
purpose then that's [__] food
but yeah I don't think I think it was a
little unnecessary to add that I don't
think he needed that for the costume
this is what I would say in a perfect
world he had a great costume but because
of all the [__] that we've done you know
that's just one of those one of those
extra you know because of all the extra
pooch perks you get from being [__]
white you know like you should see you
should have seen the gift bag I got when
I was born it was it was [__]
ridiculous yeah it was it was like a bag
full of cash it's you know if I could
tell you honestly how difficult it is
being white that's why I want to know
though why that's I'd be curious to know
why he felt like he added to add that to
it he did did maybe he didn't feel like
the costume was like clear enough he's
like I got everything you know what this
needs this he could have even just left
the mustache and what if you go as a
specific guy like Billy Crystal when he
used to do Sammy Davis jr. on SNL was in
he was not only in blackface he was in
black potty black everything mm-hmm he
went I mean obviously not underneath but
like he and he somehow he got away with
it because he was doing a specific guy
like how does that work but then Ted
Danson comes out and does a roast I mean
I'm really going far back here which
allegedly everything goes
did you see on 30 rock when they had one
of the characters in blackface
they had the girl that plays Jenna Jane
Krakowski it was really funny and in the
context it made completely sense and it
wasn't like let me let me read one more
here yeah and then and then we're gonna
let you go here another another stunning
performance here dear bill after
listening how much better am I getting
at reading out loud you know inside I'm
getting way better like a little kid
rounded out your time I start to lose
control this sentence I just make up
whatever they're talking about after
listening to all the races stories from
the last two podcasts I really like your
comedy bill I have what did they really
say that no okay I have one I wanted to
share that I have always felt I lost all
right back in the 10th grade I had a
friend named Robbie he happened to be
one of the five black people in my high
school oh jeez here we go
I known for a few years and we had a few
classes together we both took some sort
of technical drawing classes and sat
next to each other after we became sort
of friends he thought I was okay to call
me cracker honky etc this must have been
the 70s if he broke out honky I'm pretty
sure he stopped calling me by my real
name and only by my racial slurs in a
while see how I'm white and I'm pretty
laid back I didn't give a [__] about
what he called me yeah I mean at that
point if every President was white at
that point you don't give a [__] it
doesn't carry as much water so anyways
after about two weeks of being bombarded
with racial slurs see I don't even
consider those racial slurs I just
considered those you know I don't
consider this right yeah hey white boy
that doesn't bug me hey [__] black
guy doesn't it doesn't bother me I don't
give a [__] anyways after about two
weeks of being bombarded with racial
slurs I figured I would I would say oh
no well okay yeah
yes you know what it means I figured
that by saying it it would be all be in
good fun and we would have a good laugh
and it would be over oh I hope he buried
it in the middle of a sentence that's
the only way if he had he needs a lot of
words surrounding it and he better not
have said it with the ark here we go so
one day a great opportunity came along
when I walked in the room and Robby says
what's up my cracker in my head I was
telling myself to let her rip that's so
close to Gator Dan this isn't gonna end
good so while I'm doing some sort of
stupid handshape I replied to Robby
saying what's up my n-word instantly
without hesitation Robby's ancestral
tribal warrior spirit kicked in next
thing I knew I was being manhandled by a
black kid that was much bigger than me
the scuffle didn't last long and nobody
got hurt he said what's up my crack and
then you said what's up my n-word and
there was a fam it's that kind of seemed
like the comedic Lee that would flow
yeah and it would be like funny and
everyone would be like everyone in
school would be kind of like wow like
they have that kind of relationship that
they can go back and forth with that
well this actually sounds like a really
bad sitcom it's alright let's finish
here we go after the fight we got into a
twisted debate on how I was somehow
wrong for what I said and that Robby
wasn't it was some it was some complete
[__] like a bunch of [__] afraid
of appearing racist none of the other
white kids in my class had my back to
this day it still amazed me how
sensitive people are when it comes to
racist [__]
Robby could clearly dish it out but he
couldn't handle any heat directed toward
him I didn't give a [__] what he called
me but [__] right there should have made
up some [__] he never [__] what he
called me because I knew he was just
joking around when I sided joke around
Kennedy flipped out we still remained
friends throughout high school to this
day I feel as if I didn't do anything
wrong but I still feel as if I lost the
argument what do you think I think
that's one of those things where
maybe it becomes because it was too many
other white people around but it was one
of those things what he should have got
at least two minutes for instigating on
that run you know fighting one gets two
minutes video cuz I could see where they
were in private they might have said
that to each other and laughed but if
there's other people around then his
friend feels like embarrassed and
humiliated and like oh you're letting
this guy say whatever you want so you
know but this is like this kind of like
reminds me of when black people say that
we shouldn't be so casual about the
n-word because it makes white people
think that you guys can just say it to
us because we say it to each other all
the time you guys say to each other all
the time I don't see what the big deal
is rappers and stuff you guys are
constantly saying it so it's like now
there's a problem if I say it
yeah it's clearly not the same thing
however I do see that side of the
argument where it's like well and a lot
of it's from like older black people too
that are like you know you can't keep
saying it like that because white people
will think that we don't respect
ourselves and so they should neither
blah blah blah all right let me let me
go back to the white guy go what what
you guys say to each other that's just a
racist for the most part that's just a
racist white guy trying to acting as
rationalize yes saying the n-word is an
irrational I'm trying to get away with
it yeah yeah yeah okay I would say
pretty much that's what that is
I never I don't think his friend should
have opened the door to use that kind of
language and I think his friend was kind
of enjoying the fog I call him cracker
and honky I think he liked that that he
could just say that to him and it might
have been like some sort of subconscious
like yeah see I can say whatever I want
you can't say [__] to me I could and
then when he did it was like no you
can't which isn't exactly fair well
depends on how he said it if he went a
little high-pitched and try to say it
like funny I think he could have done
like that what's his face do your
impression of the p90x how does how does
he always greet the black guy on it they
just see no no say say the white people
first be like hey Sharon
heõs hey yeah you're doing Billy how's
it going Tommy looking good how you
doing Nathan
[Laughter]
that's just embarrassing I was speaking
of embarrassing I asked last week who
was the last white guy to win an NFL
rushing title and I actually got two
interesting answers okay the last time a
white guy wanted for the conference mark
van Egan wanted for the AFC in 1977 but
Walter Payton won the overall rushing
title and Jim Otis won in 1975 that
doesn't sound like a white guy name
doesn't Jim Otis know either way with
that yeah
Ottis Anderson for the st. Louis
Cardinals he wanted and I think Oh Jay
Simpson won at that year speaking of
white people we were watching in high
school and I went to you know pretty
much an all-white high school there was
definitely some black people there but
not as many as away people so you guys
like high-fiving is every other white
person fainted
it was weird yeah it was a weird thing
because it's like yeah we were watching
it in class you know when we should have
been learning but we're watching in
class and then so the verdict and the
like you can feel them wanting to sell a
like wanting to be like no and then them
looking at me and you know looking at
maybe the other one other black butts
and I remember this guy coming out to me
he goes listen I'm not racist killed
that white [__] but I think I think I
think he should have gone to jail and I
was like okay and I said well he's not
and he goes well and then he just walks
away
and they probably mumbled some other
[__] um but he just felt the need to let
me know right well that's one of those
things where black people being happy
were the same that was just like the
white guy rooting for BYU because they
just you know white guys have not
succeeded in basketball and round you
guys haven't done so well in the trials
not so much yeah history so it was less
about
that he clearly did it then the fact
that you know no he didn't cuz he he
wrote that book where he said if he was
gonna do it this is how totally
different the book never even came out
first pack of football cards I ever got
Oh Jay Simpson was was was that was the
first one and I [__] love the guy he
betrayed you guys more than he betrayed
us outlook which is the ultimate irony
he I can't even say what I wonder how I
feel about that [__] but I'm gonna tell
you this there is actually a picture
somewhere in the Attic of my life of me
in second grade
sitting on Santa Clauses lap with a no
Jay Simpson Jersey owner sticker on my
hand because I had a good day at school
or some [__] oh I just remembered
another example of let me finish in a
black face well let me let me finish the
rushing title last white guy to overall
win a rushing title like no [__] was
1962 Jim Taylor for the Green Bay
Packers and he wanted in between Jim
Brown I don't know what happened to Jim
Brown that year but uh so he wanted so
they go that that's essentially the pot
yeah it's a podcast for this week I got
a rest up to do my Glee this week you
know what song I'm singing you know you
shouldn't say let it be a surprise let
it be a surprise
alright does everyone know when the tune
in oh yeah it's Glee on the Glee Network
what's the last thing before I sign off
here because I gotta upload this [__] no
I just wanted to talk about really
quickly I had a boyfriend in college and
okay yeah thanks for the great time hey
listen I I know I do have a couple more
tops everybody your [__] boyfriend in
college our relationship is when he was
a little kid
and he was dressed as a hobo for
Halloween he was white by the way and he
put dirt on it like he wanted to put
like brown makeup on his face to look
like dirt so he'd look like a dirty hobo
and it looked like people were like do
you think all black people are homeless
if he was like I just want to be dirty
so it was which may be even worse but it
was hilarious really isn't oh you know
cuz is the fact that he told you that
story I can see how far into the
relationship you are which means other
things were going on which I really
didn't need to know all right here's one
best teacher ever listen to this guy
this I got this from a teacher where the
[__] was this guy when I was in high
school hey Bill first of all love your
podcasts and your standup thank you the
reason why I'm writing to you is I'm a
math teacher and I have a student who's
a class clown I really think he has the
potential to be a great stand-up
comedian and I want to suggest that to
him as a potential future for him I
don't think that academics is really his
thing what would be some good things
slash advice to show slash tell him
right right I have being the [__]
teacher be like you sit there and shut
your [__] mouth mm-hmm make him clap
the erasers or whatever the [__] these
kids do nowadays this guy's actually
actually broke the guy back I said what
I always say write five minutes of [__]
you think's funny sign up for an open
mic when they call your name go up on
stage and there you go don't judge
yourself the first 10 to 15 times you do
it 10 times I would say it's all about
being like wow I'm holding a microphone
I'm really doing that they really do
have brick walls behind me as you're
trying to remember your [__] but after
10 times then you start getting a feel
for it and then and everything else
falls into [__] place if they have a
talent contest at a talent show at the
school he should do it too no he
shouldn't
that's what I need to tell you under no
[__] circumstances should you ever go
onstage the first time you ever did
stand-up comedy in front of your own
[__] class oh my god oh that's true
cuz if it doesn't go well it's gonna be
humiliating so he should have do it
somewhere else away from so he can work
it out so he doesn't bother
he's gonna heckle you and that kind your
balls that that is like that's why I
like bombing on a cruise ship sucks
because when you after you bomb you
can't leave just with the crowd and
everybody just sits there looking at you
and that that's but at least the cruise
is over in a week this kids got to
finish off the [__] school year but
put a love of God if the teachers
listening do not tell him to sign up for
a talent [__] contest don't do that
because that's the type of thing that
could leave an emotional scar where the
kid might not do it again for five years
or never [__] do it again okay
you need okay you need an escape plan
when you're gonna go up and do that [__]
believe me well not the first time I
have a [__] bombed oh my god oh my
god well where was the first time you
bombed yeah that wasn't some [__] bar
in North Reading Massachusetts I want to
say someplace Kelly's or something
doesn't even exist anymore yeah and I
walked in and there was this function
this little half of the bar we could sit
down and he [__] fish and chips dude
and there was like nobody there other
than other comedians and then like three
[__] people who came to see another
comedian and then up at the bar were
just guys drinking like five people
spread out amongst 15 chairs you're
eating your balls all right and I didn't
know how to handle it and I went up
there and I just bombed and said over I
was supposed to do five minutes I bailed
like two minutes in and said on the mic
I told you that Yammer said to the host
Jack I go Jack I'm bailing and all the
comics win ah and then I fell like a
[__] [__] and all I want to do is
just walk offstage get my car and drive
home but I was so humiliated i sat in
the first [__] chair that was open
which was like two rows in and just sat
there with my head down wanting to leave
the whole time and sat there throughout
the rest of the [__] open mic like a
scolded child I drove home cried classic
German Irish rather than dealing with
the emotion I kept trying to put it
outside of my body and it was just
hanging in my car the whole [__] it was
horrific I can't imagine doing that and
then doing it in front of your entire
[__] class it was horrific
okay so that was bad my bad
all right you too YouTube YouTube
[__] videos of the week this one our
Brad Garrett was on the job Behar show
if you just want to see a [__]
stand-up comedian and complete not
giving a [__] mode just going off you
gotta watch this he's absolutely [__]
hilarious this guy is a true stand-up
comedian like I already loved him from
the Ray Romano shovel and I watched this
clip this guy is the [__] and I would
definitely go see him do stand-up this
is what it takes to be a great comedian
this guy completely doesn't give a [__]
there's a bunch of people evidently
watching it cuz he jokes at all his Ray
Romano money is gone mm-hmm saying he
invested it into this comedy club like
he was on a hit series for [__] ten
years like ten years of syndicated money
that's how much it takes to open a
[__] room in Vegas when you're a name
he's clearly joking but people write is
he broke is he doing heroin heroin
no what's great is he just at one point
he's throwing chips at people who were
in Vegas here you go you're white trash
he doesn't call the [__] do it
it's [__] late you gotta see it so
funny all of these are gonna be on the
mmm podcast com we put this one up last
week but I forgot to hype it insane
robot movie you got to see this thing
it's just a clip from a [__] great
movie and also the greatest wrestling
clip I've ever seen in my life
Gnaeus oh my god he wants our five
minutes of her life back is the greatest
thing I've ever seen in my life the name
of the video is the most illegal thing
I've seen in wrestling history you have
to watch it it's [__] all awesome and
quick overrated underrated overrated the
black eyed peas the bill the black eyed
peas are terrible I'm pissed I watched
that halftime [__] at the Super Bowl
even on mute with the promise that it
was going to be something I didn't want
to miss they suck and that noise they
call music is the worst crap ever I walk
out I never watched the halftime shows
yeah they're [__] horrific they were
very different before Fergie showed up
and I'll just leave it at that okay
and if you know them you know that what
I'm saying is true
yeah if you're blaming the white girl
okay is it racist racist car sex
underrated is often unappreciated lol
there's nothing like pulling over on the
side of a busy interstate and getting it
on that's what he says or stumbling out
of a bar with some random chick you
bought a few drinks for and convinced to
leave with you going to a car and not
even not even making out of the parking
lot it's just whoa I'm bagging a basic
that's just plain awesome
I purchased let it go and loved it thank
you I would say that sex of the car was
way better back in the day when they had
bench seats and actually they made huge
cars but III think it's I don't know you
know I don't like the looking right I
don't like the [__] look in your
goddamn eye okay personal life we don't
we don't have enough memories Wow yeah
the older cars are better cuz they have
more room be kidding me you know what
why don't you get your trampy ass out of
here please me you think I you think I
didn't realize that when I met you what
is the problem that's what it took
male [__] you were a man [__] I was
not no you are a man I was always ladies
[Music]
sexy angry thing going on women like
that you know I don't like I don't like
being pandering to oh here's one last
quick thing I always say I'm gonna
[__] and and I never do alright
corporations selling your information
hey Bill I've listened to your podcast
for a while now and think they're very
entertaining and funny I do have to
admit however that every time maybe I
read this last week I can't remember
I'm just happy because they end up being
right here
I do have to admit however that every
time you talk about the conspiracy
theories and people tracking your
electronic purchases and whatnot I roll
my eyes and wonder why you're so crazy
however this is why I actually started
reading better as I pause now and I look
at the next three words and it [__]
works out now what the King's Speech
what is that what that movies about
kinda yeah it's good it's really really
it looks like it took place in another
time so that it's a period piece about
reading well that's what I was just
talking about whatever why don't you
think about your time in that [__]
Ltd however recently that's one of my
favorite cars you just ruined it you
know I'm gonna have to tell a [__]
story that's gonna ruin something for
you let me think what are you into go
into the mall Orange Julius dad no
however recently I was browsing the
internet and started noticing ads on
every page that directly related to
something I had just purchased online
how [__] up is that
now I knew things like this happened and
that sites kept certain information
about you but I guess since I never saw
any visual evidence of this I simply put
it in the back of my mind and never
worried about it however now I had
direct in-your-face evidence of being
tracked I have to say I felt a bit
violated yeah it's weird like somebody's
just sitting there watching what the
[__] you're doing anyways it says to
think that the ads were specifically
being put up for me on every website I
went to struck me as a huge invasion of
privacy and it was a bit unnerving this
was a week or two ago and ever since
then I have become a bit paranoid about
the amount of information that is out
there about me I thought about all the
times I've entered my credit card
information or home address online in
order to make some purchases and went
through every website I could think up
to erase that information dude it's over
it's already up there I know once it's
out there it's impossible
take back but I have to do what I can do
I've changed my email address my old
email address had my full name in it
started shredding everything with my
address on it and started using cash
only to make purchases so that someone
can't track it etc etc etc yeah I
actually somebody sent me an email the
other day update some four year old kid
got a got a what do we call it a credit
card application application yet from
American Express and why are we talking
about how if you use Gmail if you're
having an email conversation with
somebody and you mentioned something
like oh yeah I'll meet you after I go to
the spa next thing you know there's all
these ads for spa stuff like someone's
yeah Google reads your email it picks up
on key phrases and then just
automatically pops up ads around it that
you could yeah correlate to that email
that you Jill for some reason you're
looking at an email like like it's
illegal for you to read my mail mail
right so the old-school [__] right but
somehow online they can just look at
that yeah cuz it's just no it's not this
is what morons are gonna say that doe to
me oh it's just to compute a program is
picking up certain words like this this
is how you gradually work your way to
having a microchip in your forehead is
they just incrementally yeah take away
what they used to not be able to do and
then what happens is people die off and
then the new standard is where this new
generation was born it's like being
taken off the gold standard where cash
used to represent gold
you brought your gold and silver was
heavy it was dangerous and it was a pain
in the ass to carry around some banks
are like well bring the [__] into us
we'll give you these pieces of paper
cash that represent the gold you give us
twenty dollars in gold we'll give you a
twenty dollar bill and any time you want
you can come back down and [__] you
know get you twenty dollars in gold and
after a while we just kept using the
piece of paper people forgot about the
gold the [__] who brought the gold in
died they took us off the gold standard
now you can't claim it what happened all
that gold and silver those [__] [__]
think they kept it they kept a [__]
so that's what I'm saying about all this
other stuff is like all this stuff that
you used to not be able to do like this
people being born now will not remember
a time when people couldn't just you
know when the government couldn't listen
to and record every phone conversation
you have a [__] head and I know
people get like I know this is a type of
[__] if you talk about it people think
you're [__] paranoid well it's also
like you know the stuff that you put on
like Facebook and you know what I don't
come here I don't care I'm just
picturing you in a goddamn car with your
[__] hot-ass feet up against the
window alright this goes podcast is too
goddamn long at this point I already did
like another 25 minutes other this was
like an hour and 15 minutes can cut off
that part if you which part the part
where we're talking about the stuff with
the cars why it's probably the [__]
best part of the podcast at this point
all right look you know it's
give-and-take comedy somebody's got to
get hurt this week it was me all right
next time is it gonna be me no I
wouldn't do that cuz I gotta [__]
live with you yeah that's it listen I
have to rest up my voice because I'm
singing macho man in my [__]
underwear tomorrow on Glee that's it
thanks for watching the podcast this
week and thanks to each and every one of
you out there for making it number 52 on
the podcast that's right that's right
I don't give a [__] that's it you guys
have a good weekend congratulations to
Green Bay my condolences to Pittsburgh
and everybody go [__] yourself all right
[Music]
[Applause]
you